one of my friends is going to be like
that but you know what he was a
I got a son he's a like this with
a long ass dick
and he told he barely told me about that
he said dad you think I got a problem
why
look and I was I went like this
look at my thing and it was like long
how old is he 25. oh he says yeah well
and when he was a little baby
Brenda look at it look at her son oh
that's normal he's blessed you know but
now that he's 25 like huge
is there anyone else in your family that
has two uh no my dad was born with a big
ass big bowl like boom like a bull
and like a million sized dick you know
what I'm saying
but big balls like a bull for reals like
a Cebu Cebu like I said yeah like that
hanging my mouth
and you were born with two penises two
penis